hello and welcome to this video playing
yaffa I've never played him it's a
surprising somehow so we have a Russell
limo netherton extremely solid line for
white yep can do this as well defies the
most usual move it's been ages then
since I looked at this variation here
for black really a long time h3 may be
queen bee six
yeah playing a bit of a Sicilian at the
mode I just get too many Italian games
with you 45 just I know Rex my nerve
what to do one thing that can always be
a tricky is the night only for it looks
strong but in some cases you have to
worry that the night doesn't actually
have a square after white knight on a
three moves and f3 empat okay that it's
not happening here quickly because my
pressure on the center is a bit too too
serious let's see what is doing one
thing that I tried to do is yeah I can
this is now something else entirely I
tried to avoid the trade on d4 to not do
love him Knight c3 taking on c5 is garba
should be three ah I yet Bishop e3 that
would have been would have been really
awkward I think anyway it didn't happen
um
should be c 3 is still around here so i
have to i think go out of this IDM go
out of this idiom avoid this idiom yeah
so i have 97
just 97 how is he keeping this mm-hmm
chem 96 is also not bad
yam bit unsure Adam that it all looks
pretty good Ruby aid also looks good for
96 and deform ever miss Pitt and show
him now I expect 92 and then I wanted to
know okay didn't happen
okay hmm I actually actually
miscalculated I cannot take with this
that's not good I mean I can but it's
not not great ok some nights you for why
can't she shouldn't be shouldn't be bad
I think I should get this back on d4 and
I hope that at the end the bishop 1g3 is
not so great so we are a proxy five
awesome keep the rook active 94
[Music]
looks fairly active 92 is also possible
eh and now okay Bishop Jake's e5 is a
greedy greedy but might just be good I
don't see why not so take the center
pond
[Music]
no the peace activity paid off check
yeah if i play 92 here then queen is
seven sir is annoying I don't know what
I can play play something something
simple here like if you trade screens
via had traded Queens I would have
gotten to the second-ranked immediately
it also was pretty nice he have a parent
25 centralizing we has to know it does
not trade twins okay
so let's just activate everything
I can't go to the second rank now that
was the original idea but still looks
very controlled very centralized good
morning yeah we won the second now maybe
[Music]
it's a reason in order to take this as
may be Queen a five
check check this isn't there something
it doesn't seem to be all that clear I
mean what if tlie I don't see ya check
fled with Jack no I see one right a
success check check check check check
check check check check check check
white for fins on hey God really quick
at hand cheese Wow okay so let's have a
quick look there was always fairly happy
with my position there was just one spot
may I think he had a good continuation I
mean at least mean when I recognize
there was something I thought Bishop e3
it could be an issue I have a baby to
Hanks ok I can probably just take on me
too ok so we had and then I'm fine him
in many ways probably the move Queen c7
didn't really fit with what I did did
afterwards but it was always ok I think
I'm getting this back and I have the
more active piece position the night
coming to d4 and d5 is more weakness une
idée voice no best
rupee 5 is stronger okay but why am I
not better here our queen before I would
have still thought that black should be
better here rookie one okay I'm not
really threatening this because it's
having us hanging yeah maybe white is
just about active enough yeah this was
nice now we are just just grabbing
things check yeah careful did the normal
things maybe I can take when I was a
little bit irritated by 25 might see one
okay i'm not even using this ok i should
have taken ok this wasn't so bad just
time scramble check stuff a 92 is good
ah then I missed j.chan yeah it was
something was nice yeah I know it was a
matter of getting it done in 12 seconds
ok guys thanks for watching